you've been learning a language is this
right well yeah
um i've been i've i have been trying
well i've i've i've got my kids
homeschooling me because my kids speak
mandarin which and i and i don't and um
they grew up bilingual really because my
partner thought that if he was going to
have
kids for more kids he has
he had four already um he thought it
might be exciting to talk to them in a
language he didn't already know
so he taught himself chinese from the
ground up in a very sort of well you
could call it brilliant or you could
call it
you know really stubborn or you could
call it a kind of desire for single
parenting
uh because you know he's basically
talking to them in a language that i
don't understand so i thought that maybe
lockdown was an opportunity for me to
catch up
um and so yeah so that's been that's
been i should really be learning czech i
am aware of the irony of living in the
czech republic and learning chinese
um can you can you give us some mandarin
well uh there's this thing that my kids
i
i
said i said i think graham might want to
to hear something in chinese i said what
do you think i should
i should say and they said
and i said all right great that's that's
great what does that mean and they said
that's the
act of taking your trousers off to fart
oh wow
and i said well that's perfect i love
any nation
and any people that have a verb for that
and and they said you know so that can
be
lobbed you know someone who's you know
maybe for you gordon you know if you put
in a sort of ingredient that's
unnecessary or you just
you know you you go through a stage in a
recipe that's just a bit too far that
would be like taking your trousers off
too far
oh i see it's like butter on bacon that
kind of thing
yeah yes kind of thing yeah yeah i could
well they could i should have got them
to teach you really anyway i think
that's a useful phrase if you're going
to know one thing in chinese that's
that's not bad
[Music]